today on the matt walsh show after a
year of controversy leah thomas the
trans swimmer finally went to the
swimming championships this week and
dominated the field as expected the
media and the left have been kind of
twisting themselves into knots to
justify this insanity we'll talk about
it today also democrats in california
introduce a dog and cats bill of rights
uh piece of legislation you know i've
got to love that and a parent at a
school board meeting delivers probably
the best smackdown of crt we've heard
yet we'll play that for you plus blm
crowd funds bail for an attempted
assassin while the people who donated to
the
canadian truckers are hunted down doxxed
and shamed in our daily cancellation
we'll take a look at the new york times
article which hails our age of
anti-ambition is anti-ambitio ambition a
good thing talk about all that and more
today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know with the ever increasing
numbers of car makes and models it's now
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
why adore often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questions about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the counterman order the parts
counterman who calls him that order the
parts on his computer anyway say
counter-men
do you have what i what i need in stock
you have computers with access to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
they have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
tail lamps motor oil and even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door the rockauto.com catalog is unique
and very easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications prices you prefer
best of all the prices of rockauto.com
are always low and the selection is
always great why spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
with the worst selection it doesn't make
any sense go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh and then how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
the ivy league women's swimming
championships were held this week this
is not the sort of event that would
normally attract much attention
especially from me except that it was
the culmination of a year's worth of
controversy surrounding quote-unquote
transgender swimmer leah thomas
a male who says that he's a woman leah
thomas as you're probably familiar with
by now
uh was a man his whole life and uh for
the first three years of his college
swimming career and still is one
actually
but during that time um as a college
male swimmer named william
he ranked somewhere in the mid mid-400s
so as an athlete he could be most
generously described as mediocre but
then through some miracle of science
wonder of wonders
william realized that he is actually a
woman
what does that mean and what way is he a
woman how could he be a woman
what is a woman none of these questions
especially the last one famously have
been answered all we know or all that we
are supposed to believe and accept
anyway is that the spiritual woman who
had been mystically trapped inside
william's male exterior his male shell
finally broke to the surface which
entitled him to swim against the women
where he instantly went from 400th to
first
which brings us to this week and the
swimming championships now there were in
fact two trans swimmers on the docket um
the other is yale swimmer isaac hennig
who is a female who identifies as male
now isaac won the championship in the
500 yard freestyle last night that again
is the female identifying as a male
you might ask
hold on a second if we're supposed to
take a person's self-identity at face
value and put them in the league that's
in accordance with that self-identity
then why would a trans man quote unquote
still be allowed to compete against
women
if leah thomas is a girl because he says
he's a girl then isn't isaac a boy
because he says he's a boy or
isn't isaac a boy because she says she's
a boy i get confused
meaning that by the very logic of the
trans side
she should be barred from competing
against women
if we're adopting their logic by their
logic sure leah thomas is allowed in
because he says he's a woman
but isaac says she's a boy so then she
shouldn't be allowed
by their logic well the answer is no
because there is no logic on the trans
side the only logic if we can call it
logic
is that the people in that protected
class should be allowed to do literally
anything they want all the time no
questions asked
and that brings us back to leah thomas
who dominated the 500 yard freestyle on
thursday night easily beating all the
real women in the field and setting a
pool record at the same time
if you're wondering what that looked and
sounded like well here you go
thomas heads in for the final turn
it's going to be a race for second place
it might be
penn going 1-2 with baroque making the
turn currently in second place
and over the last half of the pool
nobody will touch leah thomas
who will finish it 437-32
leah thomas ivy league champion in the
500 free second place to catherine
broker
uh
by the way he beat second place by it's
like eight seconds i think
you know seven or eight seconds and the
the argument that i've heard from the
left on social media
and uh you know the trans activist is uh
they're pointing out that uh yeah but he
he uh or she as they would call
uh
he didn't set a a world record
so clearly it's still fair yeah he set a
pool record so he's the fastest
he was the fastest quote woman to ever
compete in that pool and dominate the
competition and beat you know second
place by by seven or eight seconds but
it's not a world record and so therefore
it was still fair
but as far as it goes thomas finishes
first katherine broker finishes second
so congratulations to catherine broker
for finishing first i mean she was the
fastest woman in the pool despite what
the silver medal may imply
though all of the medals awarded to
everybody involved in this farce are
essentially worthless especially
thomases
you know my daughter made herself an
olympic medal out of aluminum foil and
it has more value and meaning than any
medal or trophy thomas wins
and unfortunately there's a trickle-down
effect his participation renders the
entire event pointless and absurd
delegitimizing everybody involved
and undoing everything that everybody
achieves
the whole thing is a blatant totally
unjustifiable charade
women's sports have been turned into
some kind of strange burlesque
performance a parody of itself
and the left has tried its best to
legitimize it but the task is impossible
yesterday the new york times ran an
article titled
trans swimmer revives an old debate in
elite sports what defines a woman
yes well i know someone who's been
asking that same question though it is
it's not a question that was ever asked
in sports up until now
this is not an age-old debate in sports
what is a woman anyway
no it's a debate over the la that we've
had for the last five seconds of human
history
because in fact the whole attraction of
sports its value its purpose its meaning
is derived from the fact that it's a raw
physical competition between individuals
or groups
where nothing matters but your skill and
strength and strategy
the left seeks to make this realm of
refreshing clarity ambiguous
because that's what they do everywhere
and with everything they make it all
ambiguous
now the article makes the case that
the debate over william thomas is no
different from debates that have raged
in the past quoting how it says these
thorny questions over the nature of
athleticism are not new in women's
sports
they've come up many times over the past
century typically when an athlete deemed
too masculine started to win
sports authorities have leaned on
medical tests whether
anatomical chromosomal or hormonal to
determine eligibility in women's
categories while requiring no analogous
tests for men
but in the realm of elite physical
performance where extraordinary biology
is the rule science has never provided
neat answers
quote in the end it's about how we think
about who is a woman right said katrina
karkasi an anthropologist at amherst
college and co-author of testosterone
and unauthorized biography
she continues and of course sport has
for a very long period not been at the
forefront of gender equality and
inclusion so it's no wonder that we're
having this kind of debate
now the article goes on for a while
twisting and torturing itself to try to
find some way to justify biological
males competing against women
ultimately it cannot be directly
justified even by a new york times
writer so instead they fall back on
ambiguity as always and it finishes with
this
still because of development during
puberty transgender athletes may have
some lasting physical advantages in a
sport like swimming
may have they say such as a taller
height and larger hands and feet coming
up with a policy for sex-segregated
sports therefore requires making a
choice
either exclude these athletes or allow
them to compete with potential
advantages says jacob vindren an
exercise physiologist at the university
of north texas
there's no good answer vingren said
someone is disadvantaged one way or
another
but you know there is a good answer and
a simple one
males compete against males females
compete against females
if a few of the males would really
prefer to compete against females
for whatever reason and if that
preference when frustrated causes them
emotional discomfort
that's too bad for them
i'm sorry for them but it doesn't really
create any complications
because the point of sports is not to
make everyone feel happy and included
that's actually close to the opposite of
its purpose in fact
the point of any sport once the
competitors or teams take the field or
the court or the pool
is to find out who is the best on that
day
which means that ultimately you're
excluding everybody who is not the best
not everyone can be the best
but in order for that process itself to
have any meaning
everyone has to begin on an essentially
level playing field
all that means is that you know we don't
have high school seniors competing
against middle schoolers we don't have
pro athletes competing against college
athletes
well i mean you know actually high
school athletes have competed against
pro athletes
when it was the men competing against
against female soccer players and they
beat them but you know the other way we
don't do it
and we don't have men competing against
women usually
if those basic walls of segregation are
not put in place then the result is a
game but not really a sport
i'll go outside to my driveway and and
i'll play basketball against my kids but
i can't derive any real meaning out of
the fact that i win
and i do always win because i never let
them win
no one's going to give me a trophy for
being undefeated against eight-year-olds
in one-on-one basketball i'd take that
trophy if someone gave it to me because
it'd be hilarious but no one is offering
it
and at best that's all that this is
right with males competing against
females it's it's at best
a hilarious spectacle that's the silver
lining
now it's also sickening and infuriating
but i lack the energy to be too upset
about it because
you know i have come to see it as a
victimless crime
or at least a crime where the victims
have volunteered
willingly submitted themselves to be
victimized
we live in a culture absolutely infected
with cowardice it's what most defines
our age i think and only in an age of
terminal cowardice could something like
this happen
something that we all recognize as wrong
and ridiculous
but which few have the courage to call
as such
and so men entered into women's sports
and and few of the women fight back
a few of them you know there's a few
women who fight back and then there are
some others who complain anonymously as
um
william thomas's teammates have been
they've been going to outlets and
complaining about it
you know
not not putting their name on the
complaint
but then most just go along with it
grumbling to themselves perhaps but
choosing to participate in the travesty
thereby validating it and allowing it to
continue
if you listen to that clip again
you listen to the audience
the audience even applauds thomas as he
wins
none of them are actually happy to see a
man beat a bunch of women all of them
know all of them know that it's stupid
and wrong and bad what's going on but
they lack even the courage to refrain
from clapping their hands like gutless
seals
even that they can't do they just sit on
their hands and not clap they can't do
that
so female sports will collapse because
the females in these sports lack the
courage to defend it
and to defend themselves
it's the same story replayed over and
over again
bad people do bad things while the good
people prove they're not so good by
allowing the bad people to do as they
wish
so there are in the end very few victims
in this story but there is a primary
villain
and now he's taken home the
gold now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so after my diva like
complaints yesterday about the
background we do have a different but
this is actually we're in a new spot now
and if you're watching on video this is
totally real back here
100 real i'm sitting in front of the
cityscape of nashville
um so we actually moved to a third
studio and uh now i'm just sitting i've
got this great we're in a high-rise in
nashville and you can see the background
there
is that even nashville
yeah it is okay
uh that's where we are
listen up guys the daily wire is better
than you think what i mean by that i
mean we're much more than news and
opinion we're creating an incredible
amount of content just for you movies
comedies documentaries and so much more
let me give you two examples first
they're shutting if you haven't seen
daily wire's first original movie then
you've been under a rock the film has an
audience score of 97 on rotten tomatoes
it's a riveting redemption story
absolute emotional roller coaster it's
artful suspenseful highly entertaining
500 000 people watched it live during
the world premiere last week even the
left-leaning san jose mercury reviewed
it and gave shut-in props but it's not
just quality movies like shut in run
hide fight or the soon to be released
the hyperions or our summer blockbuster
tara on the prairie with gina carano
when you become a member you'll also get
hard-hitting documentaries like china
the enemy within which is debuting today
this is from acclaimed journalist and
writer of the plot against the president
lee smith lee is going to
show how we're all being betrayed by the
ongoing coup orchestrated by america's
political corporate and media elites to
gain power and prestige all to the
benefit of themselves in the chinese
communist party this is a gripping
five-part series that shows how fauchi
biden the nba hollywood even our schools
have become beholden to china now throw
in our investigative journalism
one-of-a-kind shows like third thursday
book club candace debunked and the
search and uh you've just you know
you've got to become a member not to
mention our willingness to fight for
what you believe in this is why i say
the daily wire is bigger than you think
when you sign up you get all of this and
trust me more big things are coming but
we need you help us build a world of
news and entertainment that reflects
your values become a daily wire member
today head to dailywire.com
watch to get caught up on all of this
new exciting content again that's
dailywire.com
watch
i want to i want to revisit this story
to make an important connection here uh
the courier journal we talked yesterday
about quintes brown the louisville blm
activist who tried to kill a mayor um
this weekend and they were they were
planning on blm was planning on trying
to bail him out and now they've
succeeded in doing so
so going back to the story says quintez
brown the louisville activist accused of
trying to murder mayoral candidate craig
greenberg has been released
on bail from the county jail so
he was freed around 7 30 p.m wednesday
after the money was put forward by the
louisville community bail fund which is
a local group that raises money to free
defendants and criminal cases and
connect them with pre-trial support
resources
so this was a crowd-funded bail
and
just
we have to keep emphasizing this quintes
brown
walked into a guy's office on sunday
and tried to kill him with a gun
and by wednesday night he's back
he's back in his own house
um or his mom's house or every wherever
he sleeps his bond had been set at a
hundred thousand dollars tuesday morning
by judge annette karam who was ray which
was raised at the request of the
jefferson county attorney's office after
that figure was initially recommended 75
000.
so they tried to give them a bail under
a hundred thousand and they at least got
it to a hundred thousand from seventy
five thousand
uh but brown will be subject to home
incarceration so he'll have house arrest
anyway
maybe blm will complain about that and
they'll say that that's no he should be
allowed to go he should be able to go on
a a vacation to paris if he wants to
so this was a crowdfunded bail for an
attempted assassin
um which which blm
got together fundraised and they
provided it
meanwhile
people who tried to donate to the
canadian truckers peaceful protesters
um
when they tried to do that the the the
website
that was taking those donations was shut
down and hacked
information about the donors was leaked
to the public
and american media has participated in
doxing these small donors let's put up
this uh from libs of tick tock they've
got
some examples of what the media is doing
this is happening
this is uh
this is not just one this is one example
we'll give you but this is this is
pretty widespread in the media right now
it says the salt lake tribune is now
using the gibson go hack data to reach
out to donors who gave as little as 50
this is harassment this is not
journalism and then we have we have the
uh actual screenshot a reporter who
reached out to one of these guys
who donated 50 bucks
says i'm a reporter with the salt lake
tribune your name and email address
appeared in leaked data from give send
go contributions to the canadian trucker
convoy
your name your name appeared to be
associated with a 50 donation
uh can you email or call me to confirm
this matches your records
why did you decide to donate to the
campaign
well here's a good response none of your
damn business why i donated to it
these are
just normal people giving forty dollars
fifty dollars
to peaceful protesters in canada
and they're being doxed by the corporate
media
compare again do you think anyone are
they gonna be chasing down the people
who donated to the bail fund for an
attempted assassin a blm
assassin who went in and tried to shoot
a jewish guy
are we going to get any doxing of that
of those
people probably not
but what we can do and i'm glad that
this uh email was put out there with the
guys um
brian scott's a guy's name apparently uh
salt lake tribune
so we got his name i wish that his email
address was out there as well
because i'll tell you the only way that
this stops
with the corporate media doxxing and
harassing regular
law-abiding people who've done nothing
wrong whatsoever
the only way it stops is if the
journalists who engage in this behavior
are docs themselves
i mean their email addresses their phone
numbers their home addresses everything
put out there
and they would deserve it
because this is the environment that
they've created and it's the only way
this stops
not just not just giving screenshots of
emails that's a good first step
but all their other information too
because these are parasites
i mean this this is scum of the earth
we're talking about enemy enemy of the
people trump was ahead of his time in
that in that label
um
there were a lot of people when trump
first started calling the media the
enemy of the people they there were even
a lot of people on the right who said i
don't know it's a little bit overboard
well that's quite literally the enemy of
the people they are going after the
people just normal people and trying to
destroy their lives why
no reason just well because they don't
agree
because they have the wrong opinions
about things so we're going to destroy
their life
now this this question of
uh whether or not the journalists who do
this should whether we should be sort of
fighting fire with fire
you know there's some on the right to
say that's not the right approach effect
someone emailed me yesterday i have the
email right here it says matt what do
you think about the conservatives saying
that we should dox the journalist who
docks the truck trucker donors isn't
that repaying evil with evil which the
bible forbids
well here's the point i want to make
it's not
okay it's fighting fire with fire
it's kind of a war of
attrition um mutually assured
destruction it is that
you know that's that's also why i would
say people who participate in cancel
culture deserve to be canceled people
who went after joe rogan for saying
naughty words
and then others went and dug through
their tweets and thought oh you use the
same naughty words
they deserve that joe rogan didn't but
they do
and that's the only way canceled culture
stops mutually a short destruction if
you if you take part in this it's going
to turn around on you eventually
right you launch your nuke the other
country is going to launch theirs and
now everybody's dead
but it's not evil with evil because only
one party is evil here
it's not inherently evil to dock someone
it's not like that's an inherently evil
act now it's it is never acceptable to
engage in an inherently evil activity
even if you have good intentions because
that's ends justify the means and that's
that's morally wrong
but doxing someone is not inherently
evil i mean there's nothing inherently
evil about putting someone's information
out there necessarily is it inherently
evil to put a child rapist on a registry
that's certainly a form of doxing
um
so you
but i think we'd all agree that it's not
so your motive and reason matter
it's evil to dock someone who gives
forty dollars to a crowdfunding campaign
for peaceful protesters that's evil
because they've done nothing wrong
and they don't deserve that treatment
there's no benefit there's no good
to come of doing this to them
doxing journalists who behave this way
is different
because they have done evil they are
evil and they have to pay for it
in order to stop this in the future
it's justice for them number one
but also it's the only thing that would
that has any hope of putting an end to
this whole
vicious cycle
all right um
okay i want to pull this up here's the
latest
from uh the latest from gallup
it says the percentage of u.s adults who
self-identify as lesbian gay bisexual
transgender or something other than
heterosexual has increased to a new high
of seven percent which is double the
percentage from 2012 when gallup first
measured it
um gallup asks americans whether they
personally identify straight or
heterosexual lesbian gay bisexual or
transgender as part of the demographic
information it collects on all u.s
telephone surveys
um
i still every time i read this one of
these surveys i i always ask the
question who exactly is stopping to talk
to these people
i've never answered a single survey in
my entire life
and if i was going to answer one it
wouldn't be about some stranger calling
me and asking me why sexual orientation
is how do you not immediately hang up
the phone
excuse me uh sorry i'm with gallop i'm
just wondering uh who are you sexually
attracted to men or women
what
leave me alone i'm eating dinner you
freak
but there are people who stop and say
well let's let's sit down and talk about
it in fact i'm usually attracted to like
what who's doing this but some people do
and um it says respondents can also
volunteer any other sexual orientation
or gender identity they prefer so so
they could also you know that you can
answer the questions and if you have any
other information about your sex life
that you want to give to a stranger on
the phone
he's more than willing to listen to it
and a lot of people volunteer that um in
addition to the 7.1 percent of u.s
adults who consider themselves to be an
lgbt identity 86.3 say they're straight
or heterosexual
and 6.6
do not offer an opinion the results are
based on aggregated 2021 data
encompassing
12 000 us adults so
that's the overall number
there's been a doubling of lgbt identity
uh
for the overall population since 2012
which is significant it's it's more than
significant this is um
you're talking about an astronomical
rise
in the general population but then
when you get a little more specific and
you look at this from a generational
perspective that's when you really see
what's happening
so uh breaking it down the gallup poll
um
yeah generation gen z millennials
generation x baby boomers and i guess
what they're calling traditionalists
who were people born before 1946 are
traditionalists
so as of 2021 let's look at this data
the number who the numbers who identify
as lgbt
for traditionalists born before 1946
that's eight percent identifies lgbt not
even one percent
and this actually undersells it because
if we were doing gallup polls you know
going back all through history
we could pretty much guarantee that it's
going to be around point eight percent
if you if there was some way to could
conduct a seance and um do a survey of
people born
in
1846
you're gonna find a point eight percent
or probably a lot lower than that
actually
then you get up to baby boomers and
they're saying and 2.6 identify as lgbt
then you get up to generation x and it's
4.2 percent
and then to millennials my generation
we're at 10.5 percent
already that is 10 times higher than our
grandparents
now generation z
20.8
identify as lgbt
nearly 21
a 20 times increase over their
grandparents or great-grandparents
generation
identifying as lgbt
and while this is happening
it is still considered
a conspiracy theory a wild and offensive
conspiracy theory
to to suggest
that there is any kind of intentional
effort going on
to recruit younger kids into the lgbt
camp
you're still not allowed to say that
even after a 20-fold increase in a
matter of a few years
still most people you talk to will say
oh no there's no this is intentional
this is just a it's a coincidence
now the the uh
clips that we played for you yesterday
at the educational conference for
private schools and they're talking
about the the sex ed curriculum for
preschoolers
introducing queer inclusion for
four-year-olds
this is exactly the result that is
intended
it's to get to them young and to recruit
them early
and it is working
as i've said before this is the uh most
effective recruit the lgbt
um lgbt activists are conducting the
most effective recruitment drive in
american history i i don't think i don't
think any other
group organization institution has ever
accomplished anything like this
and it's kind of easy you know when
you're first of all you're doing this in
the midst of total civilizational decay
and collapse and also you're getting to
the kids when they're four years old and
they have absolutely no psychological
defenses whatsoever
all right let's go to uh this from the
daily wire
it says earlier this month a democratic
lawmaker in california introduced a bill
of rights for dogs and cats
the proposal states that it would enact
the dog and cat bill of rights and would
require every public animal control
agency or shelter society for the
prevention of cruelty to animals to
animals shelters and human society
shelter or rescue group to post a copy
of the dog and cat bill of rights
the bill would impose a civil penalty
for failure to post the dog and cat bill
of rights as specified the bill would
make legislative findings and
declarations in support of the dog and
cat bill of rights
by imposing new duties on local public
officials the bill would create a
state-mandated local program
the act continues dogs and cats have the
right to be respected as sentient beings
that experience complex feelings that
are common among living animals while
being unique to each individual animal
and if you're wondering what exactly are
the rights of dogs and cats according to
this legislation in california
well let's take a look
um they they have listed looks like you
know five or six rights that they're
they are enumerating for dogs and cats
number one dogs and cats have the right
to be free from exploitation cruelty
neglect and abuse
two dogs and cats have the right to a
life of comfort free of fear and anxiety
so anytime a dog experiences fear his
rights are being infringed upon
by the way are we including just
domesticated uh dogs and cats in this
are are they the only ones who have
these rights
like uh wolves and tigers and and so on
are are they included in the bill of
rights
i mean lions out on the serengeti
i imagine they experienced it's not
exactly the most comfortable life
so are their rights being infringed upon
do we need these animal rights activists
do they gotta go and find all those
lions and uh round them up and bring
them into their homes
because i'll tell you something i would
not oppose a program like that
if you believe in the dog and cats bill
of rights in fact i i would i would
actually suggest that this should be
maybe put in the legislation if you
believe in dog and cats bill of rights
um you should be required to adopt a you
know a line or a tiger in your home
don't put it in a cage or anything it's
just equal to you
dog and cats have the right to daily
mental stimulation and appropriate
exercise
dogs and cats have the right to
nutritious food sanitary water and
shelter in an appropriate and safe
environment once again
all those lions and tigers
they don't have any shelter whatsoever
gotta do something about that dogs and
cats have the right to preventative and
therapeutic health care
dogs and cats have the right to be
properly identified through tags
microchips or other humane means
dogs and cats have the right to be
spayed and neutered to prevent unwanted
litters how do you throw that in at the
end
dogs and cats have the right to be
uh to
population control
dogs and cats have the right to be
castrated how do you throw that in after
all the stuff about they have a right to
to you know to a life free of fear and
anxiety
well i don't know about you but the idea
of of you know being anesthetized at the
at the at the vet and then castrated
like that that would give me a lot of
fear and anxiety
um so those are all the rights and it
raises a whole lot of questions uh first
of all how do you again how do you
only target domesticated
uh domestic dogs and cats in something
like this
and and also if we're saying they have
the right to be properly identified i
thought where they were going with that
is uh they also have the right to you
know to having their personal pronouns
respected i don't know how you don't add
that into the bill
and third thing
why only dogs and cats putting aside the
domestic versus wild problem
who why only them there are a lot of
other animals out there
why have we decided that dogs and cats
are special well i'll tell you why and
this is the flaw in all the animal
rights thinking and all the stuff about
how the animals are equal to all of us
nobody really thinks that nobody lives
that way
[Music]
you know because i don't care you take
the most devoted animal rights activist
in the world
and if they have a roof a roast a
roach there what someone go for if they
have a cockroach infestation in their
house
which many of them do because these are
dirty people most of them animal rights
activists
all of them are calling the exterminator
there has never been an animal rights
activist who had a roach infestation in
their house and said you know what they
have a right to be here just as much as
i do
while the roaches are crawling all over
them at night and like
you know
you know
crawling into the refrigerator and their
food and everything defecating on their
silverware
so no we
all of our focus is on the animals that
we find to be the cutest
and that we like having around
and so while they pretend that this is
about respecting the animals and it's
about equality of animals it's actually
the opposite of that it's a very
narcissistic self-centered view of the
world
where the animals that you personally
like the most and that you think are
cute
and you want to be able to cuddle with
them the most cuddly animals to you are
the ones that also have rights equal to
your own
so it all comes back to you doesn't it
damn narcissist all right um
what else we have here okay i wanted to
play this for you we've got
a couple of school board highlights
actually
here's a parent
i don't know if he'll play this the
whole thing here but he's speaking out
against crt this is a black parrot we'll
mention
and at his school board and here's what
he has to say about critical race theory
let's play it
the non-discrimination resolution the
crt deal
because it's it's happening and as a
parent i speak to other parents there's
a few things that we don't want
i'm biracial i'm bilingual i'm
multicultural the fact is in america and
north carolina i can do anything i want
and i teach that to my children and the
person who tells my little pecan color
kids that they're somehow oppressed
based on the color of their skin would
be absolutely wrong and absolutely at
war with me and i think that's the same
for every parent what the mask showed us
is that the parents the most powerful
group of people in our country that
they're taking back the wheel
now obviously we had to take the wheel
back for the mask but we're taking the
wheel back from washington all the way
to raleigh and into our local school
board because crt
all of that the parents don't want it
it's a big fat lie there's not one
belief there if you believe in crt i
want to tell you you're a liar because
that means you look at your black
neighbor and say that they're oppressed
and you look at your white neighbor and
say that they're evil regardless of the
experience that you've had with them
and we're not going to do that the
parents in the united states of america
right here in north carolina and
cabarrus county we know that's not true
because we believe the lives we live the
fact is i've been a business owner right
here in north carolina and i deal with
white people black people hispanic
people my children deal with everybody
and the racism is only happening at the
government level and on the media the
fact is you have races and there's like
you can't even find them hardly you just
hear the stories about them
but this is this is what we're dealing
with
the parents are taking the wheel i have
an eight-year-old daughter who is
absolutely dynamic
it's an important perspective too
because we talk about critical race
theory and uh you know i've pointed out
that it's
anti-white racism
which it is and we have to call it that
and we have to condemn anti-white races
because it's a it's it's the only
acceptable form of racism
left in america which means that it's it
deserves most of our attention
um the types of racism that almost
everyone agrees are bad well we don't
have to talk about it much because
everyone agrees it's bad
but his perspective is also important
too because because
it's it's quite
demoralizing
to say the least
when you tell someone
tell a kid from a very young age that
he's a press and he's a victim and
you're and you're driving that into his
head
now it's also bad when you tell a kid
that because of his skin color he's a
villain and he has something to
apologize for and should feel guilty
but honestly if i had if if i could
choose
you know if we were if we were actually
able to identify as whatever race and
decide which benefits we want to enjoy
i think i would i would still prefer
to be shouted out shouted down as the
villain
and be blamed for all of the
world's atrocities
and every bad thing that's ever happened
in history
i think i would prefer that
over constantly being told that i'm a
victim and i'm oppressed there's nothing
i can do about it
i prefer neither of those options but if
i had to choose one
i think i'd rather be called the villain
than be called the helpless victim
because when you're the help helpless
victim you have your free will is being
taken away
you know you're immediately being signed
assigned this position
and uh
so it's quite degrading and dehumanizing
so we appreciate that from that parent
all right let's get to the comment
section who
[Applause]
[Music]
sweet baby comments if you want to leave
a video comment we've got a couple here
uh let's start with clip eight
hey sweet daddy walsh my name is jules
and i just wanted to say
thank you for not changing your child's
diaper on valentine's day and depriving
your wife of her role in life
i come from a long line of diaper
changing women my parents had 11
children in 14 years no twins and my dad
can count on one hand the amount of
times he had to change diapers and
actually that's one of the reasons my
husband decided to marry me is because i
assured him that he would not have to
change any diapers from our children and
he can probably count on one hand also
the amount of times that he's been
forced to do such a roll
and take on that that challenge
so as a
newly appointed gender educator as of
this week i've decided to say thank you
on behalf of women everywhere and
mothers everywhere for letting us
fulfill our true roles and uh know our
place in life so spg for life bye
wow so much internalized misogyny there
and i really appreciate it you actually
told your husband before you got married
you promised him you would never have to
change a diaper i hope that he proposed
to you on the spot when you said that
like if you said that on the first date
that's just proposed right then and
there you have found the woman
of your dreams
all right let's go to clip 10.
hey sweet daddy walsh i just got off the
peloton i wanted to show you this
leaderboard here look at the second name
down
sweet baby gang it's going to become my
hashtag as soon as i'm finished with
this that's from roadside looks like
he's identifying as a male in his 40s in
colorado he had a hell of a ride
anyway
sweet baby gang has made it to the
peloton this is unbelievable
sweet babies for life
we're everywhere we can't be stopped
we're now
i'm not even sure what that i know what
the peloton is i thought isn't that just
an exercise bike
so you compete against
other people on the peloton
i'm i'm always five years behind on
every trend so i'm just learning what a
peloton is right now i'd only heard the
name before and so you're is that what
it is you compete against other people
and you have their uh against their
times
well and someone from the sweet baby
gang is what is it number nine
pretty good but you gotta you gotta get
into the top five if you've got it don't
don't i appreciate it but don't
represent the sweet baby gang until
you're in the top five it's embarrassing
uh but thanks for that anyway you're
banned from the show uh peyton ruth says
matt i gotta know if you had leftover
pizza would you warm it up or eat it
cold yeah i'm glad you brought this up
because something really annoys me when
i hear people say that uh oh the cold
pizza tastes better or they prefer it
cold that's of course ridiculous if if
you have the time and you're not lazy
then it's gonna be better if you if you
warm it up not in a microwave but if you
can warm it up and pop it in the oven
you know on 350 for five minutes it's
gonna be a better experience
but you you can eat it cold like it's
acceptable to eat it cold but that's
that's just out of laziness it's not
it's not it's not better cold in fact
there really isn't
there isn't any food that's actually
better as a there are some foods that
are
good as leftovers but i don't think
there are any foods that are better as
leftovers despite the propaganda that
you often hear
um
sydney says matt the diapers
don't change depending on what the baby
has expelled from their body you shame a
man who can't help his fellow citizens
by simply returning his cart
yet you can't take the time to learn how
to change a diaper to help out your
family your wife pushed out four
children the least you could do is learn
how to change a diaper your excuses
aren't valid try harder matt try harder
uh well why don't you try harder to get
banned from the show actually you don't
have to try because you are
uh sydney so you
you you just know all about my lived
experiences huh
you've seen the world through my truth
prism
and you just make all of these
statements
about me in my life
no you haven't had my lived experience
because if you had you would also know
that on top of everything else
i suffered a hand injury years ago
that makes it excruciatingly painful to
change diapers it's it's a very i can do
most things but the particular mechanism
you know of of changing a diaper for
whatever reason it causes me great pain
i've told my wife this
now i tell you i don't have to talk
about it
but you forced me to
redder says matt walsh if you can't do
the right thing when it costs you
nothing you can't do the right thing
when it really matters also matt walsh
i'm really proud that i've avoided
changing diapers for eight years and you
should admire me for it
okay except that avoiding changing
diapers is the right thing
in my case
it's the right for me and my physical
health and well-being and my my
emotional well-being and my mental
health
that's what this is really i just
stumbled on it it's mental health we
learned from simone biles we've learned
from a lot of female athletes who are
all heroes of mine
that your mental health comes before
everything
and it is it is a drain on my mental
health to change
diapers
here we go all right
logan says matt
what do you say to the claim that
communism is good in theory but just
fails in practice
well i say that claim is very stupid i
mean it's it's not good in in theory
communism in theory robs humans of free
will of their own identity of you know
the ability to have things of their own
to have a life of their own but even
putting that aside what does it mean to
say that something is good in theory you
know a system is good in theory but
every time it's put in practice it's bad
what does that even mean
if a theory is always bad when put into
practice isn't that proof that it's not
a good theory
how do we judge a good theory how do we
judge a theory good or bad but by
putting it into practice isn't that the
test of a theory it's like if i said
that my theory is that humans can fly
and then everybody starts jumping out of
their windows and splattering on the
pavement and i just shrug my shoulders
and go well it was a good theory
no it was a bad theory clearly
it might be true that i wish humans
could fly
but that makes it a good fantasy not a
good theory
so is communism a good fantasy
well no it isn't that either but you can
fantasize about whatever you want
biden just appointed a guy who
fantasizes about having sex with dogs so
people have a lot of sick fantasies
communism is one of them but it's
certainly not a good theory
um
and finally denton says i love that half
the show is just matt stating something
stupid that someone said or did and then
saying what
1010 insight and observation
hey look look then there's a reason why
this show is free okay so don't complain
well as my loyal followers
who we call the sweet baby gang likely
know my story to the daily wire shop the
swag shack is expanding almost as fast
as the left's list of pronouns why
because as a man of many prestigious
titles theocratic fascists beloved lgbtq
children's book author so many more
philanthropists there's another one it's
only fair that there are plenty of ways
to pledge allegiance to the sweet baby
gang if you remember my last
announcement i'm releasing a very
limited edition patch once a month for
you to wear on your shirt clothes uh you
can iron it directly onto your skin it's
not an official recommendation but you
could do that if you wanted to or
wherever you feel best demonstrates your
feel to the cause as promised february's
installment in the patch program is here
if you've embarked on a journey of
altered reality molded by narcissism and
blatant disregard for the integrity of
your fellow man demanding all refer to
you in a way that validates your lived
experience congratulations you've earned
the preferred pronouns merit badge
featuring my preferred pronouns handsome
and brilliant
which are actually my preferred
adjectives but you know who's counting
if you haven't gotten the bundle of the
first five merit badges there's still
time you can also peruse the rest of my
collection for shirts stickers my
best-selling lgbt children's book johnny
the walrus and so much more head to my
swag shack which we're really going with
that's what we're calling it at
dailywire.com shop and get to the latest
patch today you've earned it now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel writer noreen malone for
her piece just published in the new york
times titled the age of anti-ambition
when 25 million people leave their jobs
it's about more than just burnout
the article is long very long in fact
i'm beginning to realize that this is
the defense mechanism used by the new
york times and by their columnists and
their ilk because if they write pieces
that are rambling and long and boring
nobody will be able to read enough of it
to criticize their arguments but i've
broken through those defenses subjected
myself to the entire screed and i can
report
that it is yet another soliloquy about
how hard it is to work and how this
great difficulty has led to more and
more people uh stopping their their work
and how this is in many ways she says a
more enlightened path
than that taken by our grandparents who
were futile wage slaves blind with
hopeless ambition
malone proposes that we're living in as
the title suggests the age of
anti-ambition where our ambition is to
have no ambition
so a few select portions of this piece i
think should suffice she begins by
talking about how kovid made it so much
more stressful to work especially
because so many people were forced to
work at home in their pajamas the poor
deers
and she says quote
they log on to slack and zoom where
their co-workers are two-dimensional or
avatars and every day is just like the
last one depending on what's happening
with the virus their children might be
there again just as in march 2020
demanding attention and sapping mental
energy the internet is definitely there
always demanding attention and sapping
mental energy a job feels like just one
more incursion demanding attention and
sapping mental energy
and it didn't help that early in the
pandemic all jobs were pointedly
rebranded essential or non-essential
neither label feels good there's still
plenty of purpose to be found in a job
that isn't one of the helper professions
of course but non-essential is a word
that invites creeping nihilism
this thing we fill at least eight to ten
hours of the day with five days a week
for years and decades missed damn family
dinners for was it just busy work
perhaps that's what it was all along
now pausing for a second i agree with
her that the essential versus
non-essential distinction was grotesque
and wrong
but that's because i would say all jobs
are essential as all jobs provide people
with an opportunity to care for
themselves and their families and so
they are essential to the people doing
the job the writer though takes issue
with both labels
she doesn't like being called
non-essential but neither does she like
the pressure that comes with being
called essential
she says quote for the obviously
essential workers icu nurses
pulmonologists
the burden of being needed is a costly
one the word burnout promiscuously
applied these days was in fact coined to
diagnose exhaustion in medical workers
in a more quaint time when we weren't
heading into the third year of a
multi-wave global pandemic
teachers who happen to be both highly
unionized and college educated haven't
taken kindly to being on the expendable
end of the equation
asked to work in person with tiny people
who aren't good at distancing and
masking and have spent the past years
cooped up
right because the teachers are the
primary victims of the fact that many
kids were locked in their homes for a
year
now after a while uh you know we we get
to the fundamental complaint which is
that work in general is hard she says
it's just it's just so very hard and
nobody wants to work
it's not fair that people have to work
malone explains quote
essential or non-essential remote or in
person almost no one i know likes work
very much at the moment the primary
emotion that a job elicits right now is
the determination to endure if we could
just get through the next set of months
maybe things will get better the act of
working has been stripped bare
you don't have little outfits to put on
and lunches to go to and coffee breaks
to linger over and clients to schmooze
the office is where it shouldn't be at
home in our intimate spaces and all
that's left now is the job itself naked
and alone
and a lot of people don't like what they
see it's as if our whole society is
burned out the pandemic may have alerted
new swaths of people to their distaste
for their jobs or exhausted them past
the point where there's anything to
enjoy about jobs they used to like
perhaps that's why the press is filled
with stories about widespread employee
dissatisfaction
i was i paused every second because i
was looking for the jeffrey toobin joke
when she said our jobs are naked and
alone but i couldn't quite get to it so
there it is and then we get a whole lot
of uh stuff after that about all the
people who are heroically quitting their
jobs not to pursue a better job
necessarily but to do nothing at all to
live a life of anti-ambition
malone does find a silver lining though
she writes quote it's important to
acknowledge that some people have
reacted to this moment by becoming less
cynical about the possibilities of work
the broader world is getting darker
climate change crumbling democracy it
feels impossible to change it but work
work could change an idealistic
generation is set upon demanding a
utopian world on a local scale in their
own little busy towns
more diversity more attention to
structural racism better hours better
boundaries better leave policies better
bosses
now she says this in an approving way of
course literally demanding a utopia
is presented as a reasonable and
positive path forward
the message seems to be from this
article and from the culture broadly
that we're all entitled to be a perfect
we are we are all entitled to a perfect
and painless life and if we can't have
that
or within our rights to simply give up
stop working
of course the noreen malones of the
world never grapple with the fact
that the choice to stop working is a
choice to leech off of the work of
others because life requires work life
is work it is impossible to live without
work
you have to eat you have to live under
some sort of shelter
you need clothing you need clean water
none of these things materialize on
their own out of thin air which means
that work must be done to provide them
the only question is whether you will
contribute to that work or make others
do it for your sake
so you don't want to be a wage slave
fine but if your choice is to be nothing
instead and to do nothing
then you're making other people your
slaves
and i can understand the selfish appeal
of that decision from a lazy perspective
but don't pretend that you're taking
some kind of moral high ground
and please stop trying to be poetic
about your laziness and weakness
i'm really tired of everybody sitting
around staring at their own navels
obsessing over their own feelings
thinking about what they're thinking
about throwing one pity party after
another
okay you've noticed that working is hard
and not always fun good for you
it doesn't make you socrates
now why don't you try just going and
doing what needs to be done because it
needs to be done
without thinking so much about how you
feel about the things that you're doing
what i'm trying to say is suck it up
buttercup get a grip
try thinking about someone other than
yourself for five seconds of your life
it will be a relief trust me
one other point to make here
ambition
as the word is used in modern english
is not a bad thing far far from bad it's
essential to living a fulfilled and
meaningful life
ambition is not just about earning money
either in fact i would define ambition
as the ability and desire to do the
things you want to have done
rather than always doing the things you
want to do
what i mean is if your only guiding
principle is simply to always just do
whatever you feel like doing in the
moment
whatever is most enjoyable right now
which is the non-ambitious life then
you'll never do anything worthwhile
because your life
with your life because the most
enjoyable thing in any given moment the
thing you most feel like doing right now
is always going to be to just sit on
your couch and watch youtube videos
and that's why a lot of people never do
anything but lie around and stare at
screens because they're always doing
what they feel like doing right now
which is nothing
because i mean who really feels like
doing anything
so instead of thinking about what you
want to do
you have to think about what you want to
have done
somebody once said of writing that they
don't love writing but they love having
written
the experience of having written you
know of having crafted something with
language in your own mind is one of the
most fulfilling things in the world but
writing itself is not enjoyable often i
mean it's hard it's exhausting it's
tedious
you write so that you have written the
payoff comes at the end
you do what you want to have done
what you wish you did yesterday
so you might not feel like going to the
gym today
but i bet you wish you did yesterday
who doesn't wish they went to the gym
yesterday
you might not feel like pursuing that
difficult opportunity taking on a tough
project taking a chance whatever you
might not feel like doing that now but
you wish you did it yesterday
so do it today so that tomorrow it will
have been done
and this principle really can never
guide you wrong
if there's something that you wish you
had already done then it's worth doing
now if there's something that after
doing you're going to wish you had not
done then it's not worth doing now or
ever
this is all a long way of saying that
modern americans demand instant
gratification
we can't bring ourselves to endure even
a moment of pain or mild discomfort each
moment has to be pleasurable in itself
but there just isn't any way to achieve
anything or live a real life that way
for most of human history it wasn't even
an option to choose pleasure and comfort
in each moment
now it is
but if you do then you're forfeiting
success fulfillment joy and purpose
with your anti-ambitious life
and that's why today
noreen malone of the new york times is
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today in
the week have a great weekend talk to
you on monday godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me andrew clavin